how many millionaires are there in Hong
Kong twenty thousand dollars
there's one million millionaires in Hong
Kong which means one out of seven people
in Hong Kong is a millionaire how about
that
I'm serious I've never been with anyone
longer than three months yet I choose
you to be my queen bee baby
well welcome to Hong Kong it's the
greatest City on the planet where you
can party non-stop
Monday to Sunday
every week
for free
you'll need a VIP to back you up VIP a
very
interested person in this town every
model has one
you
want to do a party last night I'm Sean
Camila
[Music]
maybe you can change him show me all the
things you love show me your dreams
I don't think I've ever met anyone quite
like you
[Music]
get out
I have to go well how about a grad trip
to Sunday two days here you second
person try buying me
he's never been faithful to you treat me
like
it was a scam
fadine she didn't do anything
like I almost killed me we wanted to
teach you a lesson
where's Camilla's room she left to the
airport wait the airport let's go let's
go let's go
[Music]
good foreign foreign